هذا هو المنزل المستهدف والذي قصفته
طائرات الاحتلال الحربيه في منطقه المخيم
الجديد بالمسيرات قبل
قليل من على ركام هذا
المنزل المدمر كليا اربع طوابق قد
سوتهم المقاتلات الحربيه بالارض هذه هذه
المنازل التي هي مجاوره للمنزل المستهدف
منزل عائله حما قد دمرت بشكل كامل نتيجه
الاستهداف الكبير يعني كما يتحدث لنا الان
يعني احد المواطنين من جيران هذا المنزل
يقول ان هناك اثنين من المفقودين تحت ركام
هذا
المنزل لازال البحث عن هؤلاء
المفقودين طواقم الانقاض و الاسعاف تعثر
على احد المواطنين تحت ركام منزل عائله
حماده حيث قصفت المقاتلات الحربيه هذا
المنزل بصاروخ ثقيل ادى الى تدمير منزل
مكون من اربع طوابق هذا المنزل قد سوي
ودمر بشكل
كامل انتشال عدد من الاصابات والان يتم
انتشال
شهيد من هذا المنزل ولا يزال هنا البحث عن
مفقود اخر تحت ركام هذا
المن مسافه
كبيره
قد ار بها هؤلاء الشبان برفقه طواقم
الانقاض طواقم
الاسعاف
حتى يتم ايصال هذه او هذا الشهيد الى
سيارات الاسعاف طواقم الاسعاف الان
تحاول ان تتاكد من ان هذا الشاب قد ارتقى
شهيدا سننتظر
سننتظر ما يتحدث
به ضابط الاسعاف بعد
قليل ووها عند الدار خص الحين لحقونا فيها
واحد يا اودي عض الله ش الله يرحم دكتور
يعطيكم العافيه دكتور تؤكد ارتقاء الشاب
شهيد
الله ن الان ضابط الاسعاف يؤكد ان الشاب
قد ارتقى
شهيدا بعد انتشاله من تحت ركام منزل عائله
حماده في المخيم
الجديده يعني اصدقاء الشهيد وجيران الشهيد
واهله على فراق هذا الشاب الذي تم انتشاله
من تحت الركام قبل
قل يا الله شيل من ورا رجليه شيل من ورا
رجليه خيش رجلين لا
ايو
ta